Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Most of the techniques we've seen in previous
fluid papers run the simulation inside the
entire volume of the fluids.
These traditional techniques scale poorly
with the size of our simulation. But wait,
as we haven't talked about scaling before,
what does this scaling thing really mean?
Favorable scaling means that if we have a
bigger simulation, we don't have to wait longer
for it. Our scaling is fairly normal if we
have a simulation twice as big and we need
to wait about twice as much. Poor scaling
can give us extraordinarily bad deals, such
as waiting ten or more times as much for a
simulation that is only twice as big.
Fortunately, a new class of algorithms is
slowly emerging that try to focus more resources
on computing what happens near the surface
of the liquid, and try to get away with as
little as possible inside of the volume.
This piece of work shows that most of the
time, we can get away with not doing computations
inside the volume of the fluid, but only on
the surface.
This surface-only technique scales extremely
well compared to traditional techniques that
simulate the entire volume. If a piece of
fluid were an apple, we'd only have to eat
the peel, and not the whole apple. It's a
lot less chewing, right? As a result, the
chewing, or the computation, if you will,
typically takes seconds per image instead
of minutes.
A previous technique on narrow band fluid
simulations computed the important physical
properties near the surface, but in this case,
we compute not near the surface, but only
on the surface. The difference sounds subtle,
but it makes a completely different mathematical
background.
To make such a technique work, we have to
make simplifications to the problem. For instance,
one of the simplifications is to make the
fluids incompressible. This means that the
density of the fluid is not allowed to change.
The resulting technique supports simulating
a variety of cases such as dripping water,
droplet and crown splashes. fluid chains and
sheet flapping.
I was spellbound by the mathematics written
in the paper that is both crystal clear and
beautiful in its flamboyancy. This one is
such a spectacular paper. It is so good, I
had it on my tablet and couldn't wait to get
on the train so I could finally read it.
The main limitation of the technique is that
it is not that useful if we have a large surface
to volume ratio, simply because the peel is
still a large amount compared to the volume
of our apple. We need it the other way around
for this technique to be useful, which is
true in many cases.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!